Bonjour tout le monde et bienvenue pour une nouvelle vidéo.
Aujourd'hui j'avais envie de vous parler
de l'effet Dunning-Kruger.
Donc Dunning-Kruger c'est le nom des deux scientifiques ou chercheurs,
je ne sais plus exactement ce qu'ils sont et ils ont inventé un concept,
ils ont théorisé un concept
qui s'appelle l'effet Dunning-Kruger.
Je voulais parler de ce sujet parce que je pense que c'est
quelque chose d'intéressant pour l'apprentissage des langues.
C'est quelque chose qui peut s'appliquer
à l'apprentissage des langues.
Alors cet effet c'est une théorie qui est valable un peu pour tout,
mais personnellement avec mon apprentissage du japonais c'est quelque chose
dont j'ai fait
l'expérience notamment au début de mon apprentissage.
Tout simplement parce que cet effet Dunning-Kruger
il dit qu'en fait quand on commence à s'intéresser à quelque chose moins on
sait plus on pense
savoir, c'est à dire que moins on connaît de choses sur un sujet, plus on
va vite avoir
l'impression de connaître beaucoup de choses sur ce sujet.
Le graphe bon je vous mettrai une
illustration mais le graphe ça fait quelque chose comme ça et en gros ce
qu'on voit c'est que
quand on commence à s'intéresser à un sujet on monte très vite en
confiance, on gagne très
rapidement de la confiance.
De haut en bas c'est l'axe de la confiance et horizontalement c'est
les compétences.
Donc plus on va vers la droite, plus on a de compétences dans le sujet,
plus on
monte, plus on a confiance en nos compétences.
Je vais y arriver.
Du coup ce que dit cet effet
c'est que au début quand on commence à s'intéresser on gagne très
rapidement de la confiance, on
gagne beaucoup plus de confiance finalement que de compétences et que
ensuite on redescend très
rapidement pour petit à petit gagner en confiance et en compétences.
Pourquoi je dis que c'est
intéressant pour l'apprentissage d'une langue c'est que quand j'ai commencé
à m'intéresser à
l'apprentissage du japonais j'ai commencé à chercher sur internet des
manières d'apprendre le
japonais, des manières efficaces d'apprendre le japonais et très rapidement
on tombe un peu sur
les mêmes choses c'est-à-dire il faut construire une habitude, il faut
utiliser un système de flash
card etc etc et aussi il faut apprendre les mots selon leur fréquence
d'utilisation c'est-à-dire
qu'au début on va essayer par exemple d'apprendre les mille premiers mots
les plus fréquents,
les plus fréquemment utilisés c'est-à-dire les mots les plus utilisés.
Pourquoi on fait ça tout
simplement parce que ces mots doivent être une priorité puisque on les
utilise plus souvent et
souvent on dit on dit des choses comme si vous connaissez mille mots de
vocabulaire vous allez
comprendre 80% de la langue parce qu'on estime que 80% des mots utilisés
sont toujours les mêmes
les mêmes mille mots les plus fréquents et en fait je me rappelle un jour
avoir vu ce genre
d'information et m'être dit en fait c'est facile il me suffit d'apprendre
ces mille mots et j'aurai
déjà une bonne compréhension de la langue donc ça devrait être rapide je
devrais pouvoir apprendre
rapidement et pouvoir avoir un niveau moyen très rapidement en japonais et
du coup là j'étais
ce qu'on va ce que la courbe appelle la montagne de l'ignorance
c'est-à-dire qu'au début on
gagne beaucoup de confiance en soi on monte cette montagne de l'ignorance
et une fois qu'on
est tout en haut on pense savoir beaucoup de choses mais finalement on est
surtout ignorant on n'a pas
beaucoup de compétences et à ce moment là je me disais bah c'est bon
j'utilise Anki j'apprend
10 nouvelles cartes par jour pour apprendre mille mots du coup ça va me
prendre 100 jours qui équivaut
à trois mois à trois mois et demi à peu près et du coup dans trois mois et
demi je serai déjà
assez bon en japonais et ensuite il me suffira de continuer à faire ça pour
atteindre 3000
4000 mots et et très rapidement maîtriser le japonais et ça c'est vraiment
la montagne de
l'ignorance juste après c'est redescendu dans ce qu'on appelle la vallée de
l'humilité je crois
qu'en anglais c'est valley of despair donc la vallée du désespoir ou
de je préfère de
l'humilité parce que c'est un moment où on se rend compte qu'en fait malgré
tout ça malgré
qu'on connaît malgré le fait qu'on connaît mille mots ça ne nous aide pas à
tout comprendre
ou ne comprend rien et d'ailleurs souvent enfin par exemple je me disais je
vais regarder plusieurs
fois la même vidéo de japonais facile ou de slow japanese par exemple et
après je maîtriserais
entièrement tout le vocabulaire qui est utilisé dans cette vidéo et sauf
qu'en fait c'est ce n'est
pas le cas c'est à dire que j'ai regardé plusieurs fois et au bout de je
sais pas deux trois
semaines un mois où je m'étais dit après après m'être dit que finalement ça
allait surement être
facile j'ai commencé à réaliser que non que ça allait être très difficile
pas forcément difficile
mais plus long que prévu et ça c'est la vallée de l'humilité c'est quand on
se rend compte que
finalement le sujet sur lequel on pensait savoir beaucoup de choses
finalement ça prend beaucoup
plus de temps que prévu de vraiment maîtriser et d'avoir des compétences
dans ce sujet
et ensuite la courbe remonte petit à petit et là je pense que c'est quand
on a pris conscience un
peu du sujet de tout ce que ça représente de la complexité ou même de la
profondeur du sujet
on se rend compte que bah ça demande un effort régulier et que ça va
prendre beaucoup de temps
et du coup ça c'est la montée de l'apprentissage c'est une montée plus
régulière où on monte
en confiance et en compétences de manière égale quand on gagne des
compétences on prend en confiance
et ce n'est pas un excès de confiance comme au début et ça ça donc moi je
l'ai vécu pour mon
apprentissage du japonais je pense que vous l'avez sûrement vécu pour
l'apprentissage du français
et ça s'applique à d'autres choses.
Typiquement je pense que tous les contenus qu'on voit sur
internet qui nous disent qu'apprendre une langue c'est facile ça peut être
fait rapidement tout ça
joue un peu sur cette montagne de l'ignorance c'est à dire qu'au début on
va prendre très
rapidement confiance on va trouver des contenus qui confirment un peu ce
qu'on pense que ça va
être rapide que si on applique la méthode soi-disant miracle qu'on va
pouvoir y arriver très facilement
on se retrouve tout en haut de la montagne de l'ignorance et après il y a
une grosse chute de
confiance où on se rend compte ben si vous connaissez mille mots c'est très
bien mais vous
n'allez rien comprendre à une conversation native parce qu'il y a plein
d'autres facteurs bien
évidemment il y a le vocabulaire mais après il y a la vitesse il y a la
prononciation il y a la
manière d'utiliser le vocabulaire parce que par exemple quand on dit mille
mots ça représente
80% de la langue est ce qu'on compte toutes les conjugaisons pour un seul
verbe non donc le verbe
manger on va le compter comme un mot qui compte dans les mille mots pour
connaître 80% de la langue
en fait maîtriser le verbe manger ça demande énormément de travail puisque
derrière il y a
plein de conjugaisons différentes c'est pareil pour le japonais le japonais
un seul verbe il a
plein de formes différentes et savoir maîtriser ces différentes formes ça
va forcément prendre
du temps et du coup se dire c'est bon je connais le verbe manger c'est bon
je connais mille mots
je connais 80% des mots ce n'est pas aussi simple et ça je trouve que ça
c'est un peu un comme on
dit un coup de gueule mais bon tout est relatif mais c'est un truc qui
m'énerve quand je vais sur
les réseaux sociaux du coup où je vois plein de vidéos qui disent ouais
voici la méthode utilisée
par les polyglottes que personne ne connait et vous allez apprendre le
français en un mois en deux
mois peu importe en moins de six mois je trouve que c'est déjà compliqué et
ça en fait je trouve
que ça et ça joue un peu sur une sorte de fomo donc fear of missing out de
fomo et que ça joue
un peu sur cette montagne de l'ignorance c'est-à-dire qu'au début on pense
qu'on va très
rapidement apprendre une langue et tout ce tout ce marketing un peu
bullshit désolé je suis un peu
énervé mais tout ce marketing un peu bullshit il encourage les les gens à
monter cette montagne
de l'ignorance à prendre beaucoup de confiance sans forcément gagner en
compétences et du
coup plus cette montagne va haut plus la redescente va être brutale plus
la descente va être
difficile et le problème en soi que encourager les gens et leur dire vous
pouvez y arriver en deux
mois c'est bon c'est un peu mentir en soi mais soit le problème c'est que
quand cette confiance
redescente d'un coup là dans la vallée de l'humilité dans la vallée du
désespoir c'est là où
les gens abandonnent en fait c'est là où les gens arrêtent d'apprendre une
langue alors que la
partie la plus intéressante c'est ce qui vient après c'est l'apprentissage
progressif et
surtout constant avec les compétences qui montent en même temps que la
confiance et du
coup j'ai un peu l'impression que toutes ces vidéos tous ces contenus qui
disent vous pouvez
être bilingue en français en trois mois et j'exagère un peu mais vous
pouvez maîtriser le
français en cinq mois ben finalement derrière ça va générer de la
frustration et ça va
décourager les gens au moment où ils vont tomber dans cette
vallée de l'humilité
et ça c'est dommage parce que je pense que justement il faut encourager les
gens au moment
où il perd un peu cette confiance ou au moment où il se rend compte que
finalement ça va prendre
plus de temps que prévu et que dans tous les cas ce n'est pas un sprint
c'est plus un long
voyage dans lequel il faut s'embarquer dans lequel il faut s'investir pas
forcément en passant
trop de temps mais de manière régulière et constante et typiquement
récemment j'ai fait un
réel sur instagram où je parle d'une vidéo qui dit que qui présente ... c'est
quelqu'un qui marche
dans la rue et qui parle à une personne japonaise dans les rues de paris et
qui parle assez bien
japonais qui parle un japonais d'un peu de tous les jours et quand la
personne japonaise lui demande
pourquoi comment est-ce que vous avez appris le japonais depuis
combien de temps est-ce
que vous apprenez le japonais et là la personne répond ça fait un mois que
j'apprends parce que
j'utilise cette application et au début vraiment au début en regardant
cette vidéo ma réaction
c'était au début je vois la personne qui parle et tout et je me fait "trop bien,
trop cool il parle
japonais c'est trop bien de pouvoir aller voilà parler avec les gens comme
ça" et le moment où
elle dit comment vous avez appris le japonais là je me suis dit oh non non
c'est du marketing et là il
répond un mois et j'ai fait ouais je vais être un peu vulgaire mais je
crois que j'ai dit "roh ta gueule"
arrêtez avec ça arrêtez avec ce marketing bullshit parce que ça crée plus
de mal que de bien
finalement bon forcément ça amène des gens à utiliser l'application qui je
ne sais pas si
elle est vraiment bien mais c'était une application de flashcard que
personnellement moi j'utilise
enfin j'utilise une autre application mais c'est le même système mais je
trouve que ce genre
de choses ça ça va juste décourager les gens et du coup je pense que au
début il faut encourager
les gens à apprendre la langue il faut leur donner un peu l'envie les
méthodologies dans
tous les cas il va y avoir un peu de cette montagne de l'ignorance il va y
avoir un peu une
redescente et c'est là où il faut encourager les gens à faire un petit peu
chaque jour pour qu'ils
continuent un peu ce voyage dans l'apprentissage d'une langue et donc c'est
pour ça que je trouve
que cette courbe est vraiment très importante et si je prends l'exemple du
japonais au début
voilà je me disais en un an ça va être bon et quand je regarde sur internet
les personnes
qui apprennent le plus rapidement le japonais il y en a deux et c'est en un
an et demi deux ans ils
ont eu un niveau n1 c'est le test de japonais niveau n1 en un an et demi ou
deux ans ce qui est
énorme enfin ce qui est hyper rapide mais ils disent bah je travaillais
cinq heures par jour
et un an et demi deux ans en plus le test de JLPT c'est un test de
compréhension donc ce n'est
pas forcément un test d'expression mais tout ça pour dire que même en y
allant à fond avec les
bonnes méthodologies etc ça va prendre des années et c'est pas grave au
contraire c'est justement
je pense que ça donne de la valeur à cet apprentissage je vais faire un peu
le boomer mais aujourd'hui
on a tout un peu trop facilement on a tout à disposition assez facilement
et je trouve que
justement se remettre dans quelque chose qui prend du temps qui demande un peu de s'investir
ça donne de la valeur à ça et c'est quelque chose d'important je pense
qu'apprendre une langue ça
ne s'achète pas on ne peut pas l'acheter avec de l'argent on ne peut pas
vraiment tricher et du
coup quand on apprend une langue on est vraiment content parce que ça
demande des efforts et ça
demande de s'impliquer et de travailler et de ça on peut tirer une vraie
satisfaction et je pense
que c'est plutôt ça qu'il faut encourager plutôt que le discours de FOMO ou
on dit si vous connaissez
ma méthode vous allez apprendre très rapidement bien évidemment il faut
poser la question de la
méthode mais il ne faut pas être trop trop trop trop pushy avec ce truc de
apprendre très rapidement
bien évidemment derrière il y a tout ce qui est visibilité, audience
c'est-à-dire que si vous
faites un contenu où vous dites aux gens bah ça va prendre des années bah
vous risquez de ne pas
avoir beaucoup de spectateurs à l'inverse si vous dites j'ai une méthode
miracle et vous pouvez
apprendre en trois mois ça va attirer plus de monde et ça ça s'applique
d'une autre ... cet
effet de Dunning-Kruger il s'applique d'une autre manière je pense à
l'apprentissage des langues c'est
sur la connaissance qu'on a d'une culture en ce moment le japon c'est un
pays très à la mode
en france le problème c'est que quand on s'intéresse à une culture on a cet
effet de Dunning-Kruger c'est
à dire qu'au début on a la montagne de l'ignorance c'est à dire que très
rapidement on va penser
connaître beaucoup de choses sur la culture d'un pays et on va finir par
faire des généralités c'est
normal d'avoir cet effet moi même quand je suis allé pour les premières
fois au japon au début
je commençais à me dire ah oui je comprends la culture japonaise je
comprends pourquoi ils sont
comme ça etc etc sauf qu'en fait on éfleure juste on touche seulement à la
surface de la culture
et ça si on continue pas un peu de s'intéresser à une culture ça peut être
très superficiel ça
me l'a fait pour l'apprentissage ... pour la culture japonaise pardon le
premier voyage où j'y suis
allé je me suis dit ah oui d'accord je comprends mieux les japonais etc et
en fait plus j'ai
commencé ... plus j'ai continué à apprendre la langue plus je me suis rendu
compte que la
culture était infinie et que c'était impossible de maîtriser une culture
entière rapidement
ça et honnêtement je pense que ça demande une vie entière pour
s'approprier une culture
nous par exemple moi je suis né en france j'ai grandi dans une famille
française etc
donc j'ai une culture française mais ça fait 30 ans que je passe tous mes
jours dans cette culture
à parler la langue à m'intéresser voilà à faire toutes mes études dans
cette culture et forcément
si je veux par exemple maîtriser de la même manière la culture japonaise il
faudrait que
j'aille vivre 30 ans au japon tous les jours en parlant seulement japonais
etc donc forcément
ça prend énormément de temps et du coup je pense que avec cette vision là
on s'intéresse plus aux
gens qui ont vraiment de l'expérience dans un domaine qui ont vraiment par
exemple vécu
des années et des années au japon parce que même si je suis allé vivre un
an au japon en 2024 je
n'estime pas connaître très bien la culture japonaise je pense avoir un peu
des expériences
particulières mais je pense que je suis à des années lumières de vraiment
tout connaître quoi
du coup ça je pense que l'apprentissage d'une langue pour ça ça permet aussi de cet accompagnement
sur la courbe Dunning-Kruger pour s'intéresser à une
culture quand on s'intéresse
à la langue on va s'intéresser à la musique aux livres etc et ça forcément ça va
impliquer de
de retomber dans la vallée de l'humilité et de repartir un peu dans la
courbe de l'apprentissage
donc cette montée un peu régulière pour développer des compétences où
acquérir des
connaissances connaître mieux une culture et donc ça c'est intéressant apprendre une langue c'est
un peu une colonne vertébrale dans une culture et ça permet un peu de se
détacher de tous ces
de cette montagne de l'ignorance c'est assez péjoratif comme terme mais je
pense que c'est on
passe automatiquement par cette montagne donc ce que je dis ce n'est pas
évitez à tout prix cette
montagne de l'ignorance je pense que dans tous les cas on est obligé d'y
passer l'idée c'est plus
de derrière continuer à remonter un peu cette courbe et typiquement pour le
japon ben vous
avez plein de personnes qui vont 2 semaines au japon qui font
plein de tiktok ou de
réels qui disent voilà top 5 des choses de la culture japonaise et
quand on voit ça ben d'un
côté moi j'étais à leur place un moment je m'intéressais à cette culture et
j'avais l'impression
de découvrir plein de nouvelles choses et de maîtriser de nouvelles choses
et de l'autre on a un
peu envie de dire plutôt que d'essayer de faire des tiktoks là dessus
passez plus de temps à vous
intéresser à la culture prenez le temps de découvrir avant de vouloir
montrer aux autres
que vous avez que vous avez que vous connaissez une culture par exemple
donc bon je voulais pas je
veux pas que le ton de cette vidéo soit trop négatif l'objectif c'est pas
de dire vous êtes
ignorant vous ne savez rien etc c'est plus de dire que au delà de cette
montagne de l'ignorance
ce qui vaut vraiment la peine d'être fait c'est toute la partie après de la
vallée la vallée du
désespoir en français je sais plus la vallée de l'humidité jusqu'à la
montée de l'apprentissage
et la dernière phase c'est le plateau de consolidation c'est quand on a un
rythme un peu
de croisière et du coup c'est ne pas penser qu'on sait tout tout de suite
et plutôt prendre le temps
de découvrir les choses donc j'ai peut-être dit des choses un peu négatives
dans cette vidéo mais
l'idée c'est plus d'avoir ce sentiment positif de il faut plus apprécier un
peu le voyage apprendre
apprécier la découverte l'apprentissage plutôt que de se focaliser
sur l'image que ça peut
renvoyer sur cette idée que on peut connaître beaucoup de choses rapidement et surtout ne pas
tomber dans le piège du marketing bullshit des applications et des influenceurs mais
j'en fais partie je veux dire je crée du contenu et je fais un peu la même
chose quand je dis
là par exemple si un jour je dis pour apprendre une langue il faut
construire une habitude utiliser
des flashcards ça c'est ma vision des choses mais ça ne veut pas dire que
ça va forcément
marcher pour vous donc c'est plus aussi aussi à vous de prendre un peu du
recul par rapport au
contenu que vous regardez pour pour voilà pour ne pas monter trop haut sur cette
montagne de l'ignorance
et surtout pour ne pas abandonner quand vous êtes dans la vallée de
l'humilité donc voilà j'espère
que ça vous aura plus ce petit cette petite vidéo sur l'effet Dunning Kruger sur
la courbe Dunning-Kruger je trouvais ça intéressant et de toute façon ça
s'applique à plein d'autres
domaines quelque chose qui est assez universel on va dire donc voilà si si
ça vous a plu vous
avez toujours le lien de mon patreon pour me soutenir je vais continuer ce
format de vidéo
je pense que c'est le format qui vous plaît le plus sur cette chaîne et du
coup j'ai d'autres
sujets à traiter comme ça un peu en facecam et merci d'avoir regardé
jusqu'au bout je vous
vous dis à la prochaine.